Good morning, John.
2,083 days ago I made a video and I put it up on the Vlogbrothers channel,
and then a day after that, you uploaded your first video to a different channel,
because we didn't understand how YouTube works.
Since then, a lot has happened to us and to the world.
You got a new baby, I got a new dog.
We got the last Harry Potter book, we got a new president,
we found a new fundamental particle of physics.
Our videos went from sort of disgustingly grainy 240p
all the way up to crisp, beautiful 1080p,
and John, you and I, we made 1000 videos,
and John, that is amazing, I am proud of us.
That's an amazing number, but it's not the most amazing number.
Each one of those videos has been watched an average of 250,000 times
for a total of a quarter of a billion views!
If all of those videos were watched all the way through,
which of course they weren't, because some of them are pretty silly,
that would be 1,500 years of human life spent watching our videos,
and that is a number that I would feel bad about
if I didn't feel like we had actually done some pretty cool things with that time.
$300,000 raised and thousands of videos produced for charities through the Project for Awesome,
thousands of bracelets sold for This Star Won't Go Out,
over $1,000,000 loaned through the Nerdfighter group on Kiva.org,
hundreds of deep thoughts from dozens of places,
and Tumblogs full of GIFs (jifs)... or GIFs (gifs), whichever you prefer.
We've spent a lot of that time embarrassing ourselves or doing nasty things to ourselves,
which I do not regret in the slightest.
You took advantage of your son's cuteness
JOHN: Henry, we're never gonna go viral unless you bite my finger!
HANK: I took advantage of my dog's derpiness,
I sang songs about quarks, and ponies, and Harry Potter, and Helen Hunt.
Helen Hunt tweeted to me about my song about her.
I invented 2D glasses and turned Pride and Prejudice into a video blog.
We went on tour, Catherine and I beat Super Mario Brothers Wii U,
and the Swindon Town Swoodilypoopers won the FA Cup!
JOHN: Oh he missed! Oh! We won the FA cup!
HANK: We've been on the front page of USA Today, of the New York Times, and, more importantly, of Reddit.
We made new things that we could never even have conceived of without the support of this community.
The Foundation to Decrease World Suck is a real non-profit now.
We've started educational channels that both have more than 200,000 subscribers.
We started a record label, and a web series, and a conference.
I got to sing a song with George Watsky and Felicia Day.
We've made friends with really remarkable and talented people from all over the world.
We've helped create and define this creative community that I think is bound for really amazing things.
Almost every video has been a joy to make and every one has been a joy to watch,
and in all those years, I have never missed a scheduled day of Vlogbrothers,
and you, John, you've only missed one, and I forgive you 'cause you were in the hospital.
JOHN: I'm sick, that's my IV port.
HANK: There's a lot of numbers in this video because I'm trying to quantify something that can't be quantified.
Here's a number: two.
It's the number of brothers who are the luckiest brothers in ever.
So thank you all for that.
Thank you if you ever watched a video or participated in a project,
or donated to any of the charities that we have supported.
Thanks for helping us be better people and for travelling with us on this journey,
and John and I will continue to do our best to not let you down and to make great content that you like watching,
and also to try and make the world a better place.
John...
Auto power off? Why the f...?